i wanted to talk a little bit about a
system that's built
here in australia it's on the border of
queensland and new south wales it's on a
river system called the barwin
and it's literally inside a town called
borona which is sitting right on the
barwin river
so in this town called bowona there is
today
an archaeological site it's the site of
a series of
fish traps it's the largest and oldest
set of fish traps
in australia it's nearly two kilometers
long and it's a series of
stones made in the shape of fishnets and
what this entire system did
over this massive piece of a river was
create the capacity to trap fish whether
they were going
upstream or downstream and to hold them
in pens in cool
running water when the water was low and
when the water was
high and the reason that you did that
here on this river was that it was a
meeting place it was a place where
multiple different nations gathered
it was a place where multiple families
gathered and it was a place where
ceremonies and ritual
and knowledge was built and exchanged
and in order to make that happen you
needed to have food at scale
the most remarkable thing about this
system archaeologists estimate
its age to be 40 000 years old it is in
fact
the oldest known technical system built
by humans on
the planet the last time we have a
recorded use of this system
is in about 1915 so if you're sitting
somewhere listening to this and you've
built a technical system
imagine building a technical system that
would last for 40
000 years most of us are lucky if we
built a system that lasted for 10
is also a system that suggests an
understanding of
technologies in this case lithics stone
it's a system that suggests an
understanding of the ecosystem and the
environment
and one that was changing over this
period of time and it's a system that
suggests a profound
insight into how human beings work and
for me those three pieces
technical cultural and ecological are
incredibly significant
as we think about building technical
systems we need to build them with
multiple pieces in mind not just the
technology
but the ecological piece and the human
piece
it's a useful way of framing how the
current technical systems
should and could unfold
you